les hôpitaux se remplissent de plus en
plus au brésil avec près de cent
soixante et onze mille morts selon
l'université john hopkins
le pays est aujourd'hui l'un des plus
touchés au monde par l'épidémie
coronavirus depuis quelques jours le
nombre de cas positifs augmentent
drastiquement notamment dans les grandes
villes
selon ce médecin certains brésiliens ne
respecterait pas assez les gestes
barrière il y a eu une diminution une
grosse chute
aujourd'hui nous constatons à nouveau
une augmentation des hospitalisations
du fait de la flexibilisation des
personnes en général de la détente sur
les soins et l'utilisation du masque
la situation devient préoccupante selon
le journal extra 87 % des lits en
réanimation destiné aux patients
affectés sont désormais occupés à rio de
janeiro la deuxième ville du pays
la mégalopole connaît une hausse des
demandes d'hospitalisation de patients
atteints du coc vie 19 et le nombre de
morts liées à l'épidémie augmente
je pensais passer le réveillon du nouvel
an avec toute ma famille mais le virus
m'a pris ça c'est réel le virus est là
et ce n'est pas une blague
les gens doivent comprendre que ce n'est
pas une blague c'est vraiment mortel
jeudi le ministère brésilien de la santé
a confirmé la mort de 691 personnes en
moins de 24 heures c'est donc un pays
tout entier qui s'inquiète des
potentiels ravages d'une deuxième vague
ton président gr ball sonar au très
critiqué pour sa gestion de l'épidémie
n'a pour l'instant pas évoqué la mise en
place de mesures de restriction